[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEFANO PASQUALI: So what
I'm going to present today
is my personal journey
on liquidity research
that started almost 10 years ago
and, in particular, the journey
in BlackRock, where
I started to run
this project three years ago.
And the topic of liquidity is a
typical financial problem that
is very difficult to solve.
That's why the papers and
research on liquidity,
they arrive pretty
late in the industry
and in the standard methodology.
And because of sparse
data, because of--
or sparse, noisy data
or multidimensionality.
So this is a typical
type of problem where
machine learning can help, OK?
So what I'm going to
show to you is, first
of all, what is the AI for us.
So what I think is
the right uses for us
in finance in particular for
my specific project for machine
learning, AI.
Why and when in finance,
in particular in liquidity,
the problem of hunting
for performance,
but be aware of our black boxes.
And I will present some model.
I will review the model
we already implemented
and give you a tour
of the lab models
that we are testing in the lab.
So a little bit of names.
So for me, machine learning is
making sense of a large data
set, recognizing complex
patterns in the data,
and is being able to
account for non-linearity
and getting rid of other
mathematical assumptions,
like assuming linearity
of some behave
or some of the features
or normality, all
this kind of stuff.
The typical mathematical
assumptions,
they were done in what I
call Quant Finance 1.0.
To me, machine learning--
I prefer to use the word
"machine learning" than "AI."
So far, my machine
is not intelligent.
It's just a machine that
can crunch out the data
and extracting
patterns in that data.
And some of these factor
behaviors are good for me
as features in the job
of forecasting liquidity
in our security level, portfolio
level, redemption at risk,
or whatever we do.
There are some cool names here.
These are the ones dear to me,
because I started many years
ago to approach to leverage
and allow cluster analysis
in these types of problems.
Pattern recognition is
what I say, regression,
because now everybody is
ashamed to say "regression."
No, we still use regression.
And I'm not ashamed
that last quarter we
allowed free model
reproduction of two
based on machine
learning approaches.
And one was linear regression
with two variables.
Does its job.
No shame in doing that.
So I am a guy looking
for innovation.
I am dreaming to be able to
build for liquidity default
to serious deep learning model.
Interpretability
is not a problem.
I'm going to mention to you.
But if you have something
that does its job
and is a simple,
interpretable model,
two variables, inner
regression, take it.
Now, machine learning
is not that one.
So it's not a robot.
In particular in finance.
Think about finance.
We have a fiduciary
role to our clients.
So I'm building a model,
providing the analytics
to a portfolio
manager or a trader.
And this guy is making
business decisions
with other people's money.
So we cannot use black
boxes, things that we cannot
understand.
So for me, machine learning
is a [INAUDIBLE] scenario.
Maybe one day, but not now.
And there will be enough
of all on that day
when it's going to happen.
And when you recognize
pattern in financial data,
you can recognize that pattern.
So there is a correlation
between the interest rates
and height of the Fed chairs.
So you know better than me
that if you plug these features
in a machine, whatever
is your regression,
these will be
significant features.
So now you pretend to know the
next height or the Fed chair,
you are claiming to
forecast interest rates.
So you must be careful
about this type of pattern
that the machine will include.
In particular, a machine in
the case of deep learning,
we'll use this pattern
without telling it to you.
Just set up the stage
right in the middle
between myth and reality
of application machine
learning in finance.
Explainable AI, XAI.
People love acronyms.
This is a new acronym that--
I mean, I started to see these
acronyms a few years ago.
And we must enable
the user to understand
what the algorithms do.
So basically, this is a
beautiful chart [INAUDIBLE]
by a presentation done by DARPA.
But it's beautiful to
represent the function
between explainability and
the learning performance.
So clearly, we are now moving--
in particular in our
case in this area,
the dream is to go
to deep learning.
But we still have
something to do
before we get to deep learning.
But for sure, we are able
to prove that traditional
or machine learning
methodology--
if we call random forest
machine learning and they do--
can add important
improvements on performance,
particularly now that we have a
lot of data to train the model.
So this picture is our
guideline for our daily job
when we do in the lab, we
start to push on innovation.
So our journey in machine
learning applied to liquidity.
And, again, a few years
ago when I started to
work on liquidity--
people in finance here
know better than me,
but there were a few people
working on fixed income,
in particular, 10 years ago.
There was no data.
Trades was a system where
trades data were reported
for US corporate bonds.
Highly noisy.
No competitor sparring.
We kept-- et cetera.
And there was nothing in Europe,
almost nothing in Europe.
Nothing in emerging market.
Equity, you had a lot of
data, but highly noisy.
And there wasn't a
practice about model
to forecast the
liquidity of a security.
So you have a situation where
we have a lot of data, highly
noisy, so we need to start
seeing that from this
and assemble the noisy data.
Or you have entire market, where
we have a decent amount of data
only on a small
part of the market.
And it come out with a
forecast for the rest
of the security in the market.
So the principle here--
every trader, every
portfolio manager
will do exactly taking
a bond, for example,
putting the bond
in excess, start
to put in excess some
features downloaded
by information provider.
Then, based on
experience, we start
to define the list of similar
bonds based on some feature--
rating, coupon, amount of
standing, et cetera, and trying
to pick up--
have a sense of price and the
liquidity of the target bond
and start to evaluate,
look in similar bonds.
The beautiful thing
about machine learning--
cluster analysis, random
forest that basically,
more or less, does that thing.
And you can scale and
automatize that thing.
So that one, I think,
was the first adventure.
Now, what we do here?
This is the description of
the entire overall project.
So because of this problem
of estimating liquidity,
liquidity arrive very late.
And liquidity arrive-- if
you look at best practice
for a credit model,
default probability model,
we can agree or not
agree with those models,
but there are plenty of
models from the '80s, deep
mathematical models,
very complex models.
In liquidity, there
is almost nothing--
a couple of papers almost
playing with the same three
concepts back and forth.
Is that because no
data, et cetera?
And so people was keeping
liquidity a little bit
outside the risk
managing and process.
I do market risk,
I do credit risk,
I do portfolio optimization,
good tracking error,
and then on the side,
I try to figure it out
to have a sense what is the
liquidity in my portfolios.
Now regulators gave
me a job, because they
created 10 years ago
on the sell side first.
Then on the buy
side, they started
to push for people to
adopt liquidity metrics
to control liquidity risk.
In particular, BlackRock decided
to have a more broader vision,
so really embedded liquidity
in the risk management process.
And many years ago
when I was trying
to convince my former
company to invest
in this type of research,
I was mentioning that--
you should think
about value at risk.
Why is it used by everybody
since 30 years, maybe 25 years?
It's not necessarily the
right risk management,
but it creates a
baseline out of which
compliance people,
portfolio manager,
risk manager tool
based on some numbers.
I want to address how good
or bad is value at risk.
But value at risk
creates this link.
And if you think,
embedded in value at risk,
there is one crazy assumption--
that you have historical
[INAUDIBLE] of the price--
how to reach and generate
your distribution.
So every single position
and the price 20 days
ago, you could have sold
that day your entire position
immediately in the
market at that price.
That's simply not true.
Because when you want to
unwind the position, then
you need to decide
the venue, decide how
you want to sell this position.
If your position is big,
you're going to have a cost.
So a lot of people
start to become
aware of the concept about
liquidity-adjusted value
at risk.
So this was a way to plug
liquidity from the beginning
into data management process.
So what we have to do was to
do a gigantic infrastructure.
Unfortunately for my
job, every company
I went, I was hired
to build models.
I started to build models
after 18 months, 24 a month.
The first three years
was building databases,
cleaning the data, going around
the company hunting for data.
If the data weren't there,
I convinced the big guys
to have funding for the data.
Pulling the data together.
So it was necessary to
create this environment.
That's exactly what we did here.
So for liquidity,
there was a necessity
to unify the data
we were having,
internal data from
BlackRock, external vendor,
pull [INAUDIBLE]
external information.
Crunching this with a
high-performance computing--
in this case, we
used a lot of GPUs.
We created our
research environment
and were necessarily
based on machine learning.
We called this, actually,
our Liquidity Vault.
We have all this magic data
to build the liquidity models.
Then we go here.
And the first job, we want
to build transaction cost.
We want to have simulated that.
Because of portfolio
optimizations, rebalancing,
or whatever, we wanted
to sell a specific volume
of this position.
It can be a bond,
an equity, whatever.
We wanted to have an idea of how
much it was going to cost us.
And if we wait more
time or less time,
how the price is
going to change?
So we want to build this
liquidity transaction cost
surface.
Then we wanted to aggregate the
portfolio level, the liquidity,
and this is tricky.
Because the concept of
correlation of liquidity,
the typical way people, they
aggregate the portfolio level
is trickier.
And if you start to sell
a bond in a portfolio
and you add bond of same issue
in the same portfolio, when
you go to sell the second bond,
maybe the liquidity profile
of this bond has changed because
of the first sale you did.
So here, I think
there is a better way
to approach this problem
I'm going to mention to you.
Then the other
side of liquidity.
And that, for us, as
managers, is very important.
Assuming that my portfolios
are liquid or in control
of liquidity, I can't receive
redemption for my clients
on the fund.
So I need to be able
to unwind the position
at a reasonable cost, because
I'm controlling liquidity risk,
to give cash back to the people
that are redeeming the fund
and not to hurt the
people still in the fund.
So I discovered that
the redemption at risk
is one of the most
difficult problems
ever, because thinking
of being able to forecast
that, in this particular
fund, I would have
these outflows next
week or next month
is a very difficult
problem, because it
depends on market conditions.
Specifically, it does syncretic
information on the fund.
Behavior of people depends
from if the fund is widely
used for pension fund
for other company.
If there is a moment where
a lot of people will retire,
we're going to have structured
outflows in the fund.
So there are so many things
to account in the fund.
So basically, here
is a case where
we try to clean the message
with a linear regression,
a gradient-boosting
machine less regression.
But the only way where we
found some decent performance
was using neural networks.
So the liquidity analytics
as built at the beginning,
we plugged this into a
portfolio optimization,
and our dream is to arrive to
this concept, where we have--
this is the portfolio.
Actually, it's a chart,
but it's a real simulation
of a real fund, where
you have cash, the cost,
and you want to allow
the tracking error--
you want to set pro-rata
or allow the portfolio
to optimize the
liquidity profile.
And you want to basically
control the risk.
So basically, try to have the
highest possible cash raise
with the lowest possible cost.
So you want to try to be
in this area of the curve.
And then when you have
this, you can finally
make everybody happy.
You serve, with one centralized
engine, portfolio construction,
training support,
liquidity-adjusted risk, what
I mentioned before, and
regulatory reporting.
For some things, we are in
a good stage of the project
to serve these guys.
We are still working for
the coverage in order
to implement-- to plug into
this optimizer in our platform.
But this will give you a
sense of the broader project
that we are doing on liquidity.
To honor my guest-- so the
Google people that kindly
invited me here--
I'll give you a sense of
what we are doing here.
We are using the cloud.
We are one of the first
user in BlackRock,
my team of the Google Cloud.
There are many other
people using the cloud now,
but we are basically using the
cloud for a proof-of-concept.
And that's where I
found the benefit.
So I have a couple of guys,
very expert in machine learning,
but they have day
job, liquidity.
My job is not building
neural networks.
My job is providing
liquidity analytics.
So sometimes we don't have
the bandwidth to experiment.
And having this guy
be able to experiment
and bring it up to 40-plus
GPUs to train a neural network
or using the ICPUs
instance with the 96
cores that were
available enabled
us to speed up our POC process.
[INAUDIBLE] idea is a bad idea.
So saving time or
actually starting
to invest in this area.
Now, this is the role of machine
learning in our research.
So the problem that we attacked
with machine learning--
first of all, we are doing
ML on small or medium data
sets for a moment.
We are expanding now
to larger data sets.
And I'm mentioning this
because you will not
see here a deep learning
model, because, by definition,
to do deep learning, you need
to have a massive data set.
So here we are working with
small and medium data sets.
Based on the for
transaction cost,
redemption at risk,
tradable volume,
was our big successful
story of last year.
So to one component
transaction cost
must be able to forecast
the T-plus-1 tradable volume
of a specific [INAUDIBLE].
And we found a lot of
benefits in the model
leveraging machine learning.
And security similarity--
the concept of went into use.
Machine learning tools we used--
primary regularized linear
regression, random forest,
and gradient-boosting trees.
Despite that, we, in
the lab, now in the lab,
we have a neural
network implementation
on some of these models.
Number four, the use of suspect.
So the neural network
implementation,
despite that they are improving
the performance with respect
to random forest, but not
crazy, because data set is still
medium-sized, we have the
problem of interpretability.
So we prefer, for a moment,
to roll out a random forest
approach.
And with respect to the
neural network where
we are keeping
this in the lab, we
are still researching on this.
I will try-- as you know,
synthesis is not the best part
of Italians, so I spoke a lot.
But I will try to save five
minutes for Q&A at the end.
Now, here, a hand drawing
to see how typical
the problem we need to solve.
Bid and ask spread.
Straight line.
Useless.
Because that, to you, that you
have the same cost independent
of how much you want to sell.
The theory is that every,
every, transaction cost
model in every paper, more
or less, is using a sublinear
approach, the typical
square root function.
Or you can spend hours to
recalibrate the exponent
as 0.6, 0.4 with this approach.
Those models are very poor,
because the blue points
are more or less how
the data will look.
Very noisy.
But actually, the cost goes down
when [INAUDIBLE] more volume.
Then it's almost flat around
the bid and ask spread.
Then we start to spike up.
And when it spikes
up, typically, you
don't have a lot of observation.
I'm talking about
three, four observations
per bond in a quarter.
So how can you fit the
model in that area?
So the real curve
is the green one.
The theory says,
try to calibrate
a model using the red one.
And now we think that
neural network approach,
deep learning, we can
help a lot in the future
to actually go non-parametric,
and going to fit much better,
and forecast much
better this curve.
There is typically
the 3D problem.
So I want to have a
model that, together,
can account for the slippage of
the curve in functional time.
So now if I have a cost
of 10 basis points,
starting 10 million,
if I wait more time,
I will be able to
lower the cost.
So that's definitely a problem
people are trying to solve.
And the similarity constant--
this is very important,
because it's something
that you must account when
you build liquidity models.
Bond 1, Bond 2.
Assuming that this
is a good curve.
Stay with me now.
I'm selling something in Bond 1.
Eventually, I'm going to
shift the curve of Bond 2.
So when I'm going to
go to sell the Bond 2,
I have a different
transaction cost curve.
And this [INAUDIBLE]
can be attacked,
this problem, using
security similarity,
making a linkage
between securities.
Google has the Knowledge
Graph, a similar concept
about this-- making a
link between entities--
in this case, security
in general or bonds.
Now, the data.
First of all, let me go back.
Whatever equation curve you
use, you have observed cost
and you are aiming to train
a model based on this cost.
People coming from
other sectors-- that's
why I asked the question
before-- they think,
OK, in historical series of
something that I observe,
that's the Bible,
that's true, and now I
can train my model,
whatever model it is.
In finance, I'm sorry, the
situation is not like this.
To provoke you to understand
this concept, here I did--
this is my transaction
cost cooling function
of volume traded within a
spread [INAUDIBLE] volume
and other features.
The independent
variable is this,
called Implementation Shortfall.
It's the differential
between a trade
that I did and
dimensional price.
So the market was at this level.
I trade at this
level or this level?
This definition is the cost
that I got in the moment.
I looked at the cost,
I trained the model,
and tried to forecast in
the future of this cost.
Here is a very liquid bond.
Very easy.
It's a telecommunication bond.
Between 3%, 4% coupon.
Maturity, 2022.
And to calculate this
implementation shortfall,
our trades [INAUDIBLE]
3D information provided.
Everybody claiming, I
give you the right price.
Look the three curves.
So now you're
trading at whatever
it is-- a linear regression
or a neural network.
When you are here,
you are in trouble,
because you don't know
what is the truth.
So I told to my guys, I'm
sorry, guys, but 60% of your job
is [INAUDIBLE]
and cleaning data.
This is something that
we have to do internally.
That's why the application of
machine learning in finance,
there are many reasons,
but the fact that we
are dealing with real money, but
as well this type of problem.
Data to train the models
are often not available
or, now that they're
becoming available,
can be very noisy,
very inconsistent.
Now, what do we do here?
This was the
implementation shortfall
that I mentioned before.
So we have our benchmark price.
We execute a trade.
The differential is
our observed cost
out of which we train our model,
whatever methodology we use.
And our model is defined
on many important features.
Fixed cost-- typically
the bid and ask spread.
The volume forecast.
I know that this bond has
high level tradable volume.
Whatever I want to sell,
I have a lower cost.
A bond with lower tradable
volume in the market,
if I grow closer
to this level, I'm
going to have a
spike with the cost.
And other features.
And I show this diagram,
because for a moment,
instead of going wild
and deep learning,
all this kind of stuff, we did
the entire transaction cost,
we only, for one component
of the transaction cost,
we used machine learning.
And now we are attacking
the other part.
And here we use random forest.
We have an implementation in
the lab with neural network
with the same problem--
interpretability.
And this is very important,
because this model now
is in production.
It works very well.
So far our customer, the
traders are very happy.
The problem that I think about--
let's assume that I
have the perfect model.
I don't, by the way, but I
have a decent performance.
Tomorrow I forecast
for a specific bond
a big drop in
tradable volume, so
as a signal, very severe
warning for our traders.
They need to do something
about that or not.
Kind of quarantine the bond.
If you have to unwind some
position, not that one,
or start to sell.
To implement a strategy to
hedge half from this liquidity
risk on this bond.
If I say there is a drop of
50% of the tradable volume,
it's a big thing.
Next thing the guy
is going to ask me--
why?
And I cannot tell to him, I
have a beautiful deep-learning
model.
I have it tested, I'm cool.
My guys, as smart
computer-sense people,
take it, because this
guy is making decisions,
trading real people's money.
That's why, in neural
network, we can pick up
some sort of interpretability.
Sorry, in a random
forest, we can pick up
some sort of interpretability.
Now I can say to the guy,
I have an example here.
Why the model is moving?
It's forecasting
something different.
So only on the
volume forecast where
is this framework, where
you're applying neural network.
And we basically--
now I don't want
to go into too much details.
I'm happy to provide to
you offline some details.
But here, what we
do here, we trade
through random forest,
one on empirical data,
using empirical
volume data; and then
other one based on features in
absence of transactional data.
So we are able to
leverage to have
a guess of the tradeable
volume for a bond that
never shows volume.
A bond that never shows
volume, for example,
doesn't mean that
it's in liquid.
It's a bond that
[INAUDIBLE] trade,
but you can go to
trade this bond easily,
or it's a signal that
this bond is untradeable.
And then we have some concept
of a probability of trade.
So we separated
the model in trying
to define the probability,
how is the probability
that this bond's going to
trade and then when it's
going to trade, which
is the expected value.
And this model so far
is working pretty well.
And it's the one that has
a neural network parallel
approach on this.
Transaction cost overall.
I'll tell you this sad story
of the progress of this model.
It's very important.
So we have an initial model,
a linear regression model
based on the intraday data.
The X means very poor
[INAUDIBLE] performance.
I can tell you, only between
us, that the [INAUDIBLE]
performance of
this model was 1%.
So pretty low.
The reason why I'm putting
these dots and not the numbers--
because some people
in my company,
they warned me,
listen, you're going
in front of Google people.
And there will be a lot
of non-financial people.
And then you're going to
brag about the performance
on the last line that, in
finance, is a very big number.
I would say, in finance,
it's a ridiculous number.
Well, not ridiculous,
but a low number.
So just to avoid the
credibility issues with you,
I hid the number.
So I've been discovering, no?
So the fourth one was very bad.
When I went to intraday
data, I did some work
on defining better the
implementation shortfall
that I mentioned before.
The model was OK.
Then we started to do
partitioning on the universe.
So we started to
separate buy and sell.
Then we started to separate--
if you think we started to do
a concept of manual cluster.
We are bucketing the universe in
more and more generalist groups
and fitting the model
within each group.
And if you think, in one
shot, a random forest will do.
And now we are working a lot
on a generalized additive
model, non-parametric
model like random forest.
And we are, as well, in the
lab, testing neural network.
This is neural network for
the entire transaction cost.
So not only one component.
We expected that if we train the
model of a big amount of data,
the performance
will be very high.
I don't know yet.
Next event, you will
know how the model works.
So far, we've rolled
out in production
this model, based on
its aggressive approach,
based on the partition
of the universe.
Now we are generalizing
this with cluster analysis
and random forest.
That's our next step.
But so far, we've rolled
out, in production,
this model that is using the
ADV based on random forest.
And so far, the model
performs pretty well.
To give you some story of the
evolution of our experiment.
This is an example
of November 2000--
OK, my company was
very lucky to have,
in the last four years, any
serious liquidity stress.
For me, it was a damnation,
because I have nothing
to train the data
on liquidity stress.
So I say this against the
interest of my company now.
I needed some bad moment,
so I can verify my model.
Otherwise, everything's
good, my model is good.
Something like this
happened in November.
There was some
stress in the market,
particularly in
corporate bond market.
And we are very
happy to see that,
from beginning of November
up to Thanksgiving,
where the stress was
very evident to manifest,
there was a situation.
That's why we have a job.
Situation where portfolio
manager, they were ordering--
OK, I need to unwind
this position.
That's fine, because bid and
ask spread is not moving.
And the traders say,
I'm sorry, but when
I go to trade these guys,
it's more difficult.
I have a higher cost.
And there was this
connection between the two.
The concept of liquidity
doesn't depend necessarily
of observability
within a spread.
It can depend from
many other features.
So the entire
model, we are able--
this is something that you
cannot do in neural network.
So I was inviting
[INAUDIBLE] spotlight,
Google to find a solution.
This is something that you
can do in random forest.
This is the evolution for
a group of three bonds.
The issuer, average behavior
of the transaction cost
across November.
And the transaction cost went up
a lot in terms of basis points.
So what we could
unwind here were
very different to what you could
unwind at the end of the month.
And you see that
duration times spread
was backing up as expected.
Within a spread,
it's almost flat.
Bid and ask spread in that
month actually went down,
even counter-intuitively.
It was 0.2 basis
points, so nothing.
But ADV was dropping.
And interestingly, the number
of dealer runs was dropping.
So once the feature
was used, it's
just simply count how many
dealer runs are contributing
to this bond.
It's a measure of interest.
I know that there are
some Google people there
that are going to have a lot
of ideas about the [INAUDIBLE]
and stuff like this.
But for the moment, for us,
counting how many dealer runs
are contributing a
bond is an indication
of interest around this bond and
making bids around this bond.
Now, this number drops.
For us, it's a warning.
The model reacted to this.
So bid and ask spread
that is technically
the main driver of transaction
cost wasn't moving,
but the other features, less
important, a lot of them,
they were moving.
And finally, the transaction
cost was doing a good job.
I did my test.
I claimed the model was done.
Now I don't want any more
stress in the market,
because it was a very
painful month for me.
Anyway.
But this is exactly the reason
why we are doing this job.
So now we can provide a signal
[INAUDIBLE] to the traders,
and we can attribute this
to the input features.
Idea for next step.
Very quick, I mentioned to
you that we have, in the lab,
generalized additive
models that we tried.
And for this different
group of markets,
we improved the performance of
the model of 6%, 22%, and 11%.
And that's very natural.
It's a kind of fitting
sublinear model, different model
for every band of volumes.
So it's the orange curve.
If you remember, it's exactly
similar to the empirical shape
of the data in the first
slide I showed to you.
Going down, then up.
Then one thing, with
my guys, we start
soon in the lab is a leveraged
reinforcement learning
on the transaction cost level.
And this, we think,
is going to be
performing very, very
well, technically,
and particularly useful
for stress testing.
I have nothing to say to you
now, because we need to start.
We are configuring
the environment
to do this experiment.
But this is an evolution
of the transaction cost
we're going to do.
Similarity.
This is our-- and I've
been bragging about this
and talking about
this for 10 years.
So we have now
different methodologies
to be able to define
given the first bond.
In this case, I picked
up oil company bonds.
Similar bond, this is
completely done by the machine.
So here, I can use
cluster analysis.
I can use
gradient-boosting tree.
You can use neural network.
And again, if you
use neural network,
you're going to have an
interpretability problem.
But we are very
happy about this.
And now you see that two
total bond are very similar.
If you start to do some trading
activity on the first one, when
you go to make a trade
on the second one,
you're going to have a
different liquidity profile.
And so we are basically
defining this similarity base
on how the securities are
highly connected or not.
There is a model we are
implementing about this.
So in the security similarity,
we have distance-based metrics.
That is done.
We are testing using
gradient-boosting trees.
And next, we're going to have
semi-supervised variational
auto-encoders and potentially
a knowledge graph.
I do believe that the
knowledge graph concept--
I don't know yet--
will be the answer in
terms of a methodology tool
to do this job.
Again, to honor my guests, about
interpretability, in this case,
interpretability becomes
much more important
than other cases,
because this will
be used widely,
technically, even
for portfolio construction.
Many people were investigating,
but these two papers
are done by Google people.
I think it's DeepMind
people, I think.
So this is basically what
we are doing in the lab now.
The title here is
Redemption at Risk,
The Beginning of Our Artificial
Neural Network and Cloud
Adventure.
Because if you think
about regressive models,
random forests based
on now a lot of data,
but not petabytes
of data, you can
work in an internal
infrastructure and databases.
Random forest was a
difficult problem,
so immediately, we started to
end in some performance issues.
Then we opened a personal
account on the Google Cloud.
Literally.
The first one was
a personal account.
We started to make
experiments, then
we opened a corporate
account on that.
And basically, the story here--
so we did this first experiment
without the data just
to understand how the
cloud was working.
Then we got approval to upload
some of our data in the cloud
officially, as a
company under contract.
And we were able to do
this experiment, using
an embarrassing
amount of factors,
because running the
redemption of the fund
has a crazy amount of factors.
Using three ensembles
to filter the features
and then fit in our networks.
And the model we
are building is time
to forecast a CDF that we
can transform in a PDF.
It's telling to us the
probability of-- we
are not forecasting the
size of the redemption.
I would be a very rich
guy if I could do that.
We are trying to
forecast the probability
of large flows, where
large is a flow bigger
than a certain threshold.
So basically, you take your
slice on this 3D picture,
and then you use
that distribution
to do your forecast,
a distribution
conditional to all
the input factors.
This is the only way we
could have a somewhat decent
performance in this model.
Not crazy big, but a good
performance, something that you
can use in the daily life, and
it was the only way to do that.
Now, we are working
now in trying
to make sense of this model
for day-to-day users because
of interpretability.
Another case that
we are working on.
I don't have to tell
the people in finance
here that, in particular,
bonds trade over the counter.
This data is unstructured, and
there is not a quantitative way
to determine the accuracy
of the dealer quotes.
Dealer quotes are the big source
of everybody, us included.
Every vendor I'm
using is because trade
are very rare, sparse.
The information from
dealers are what people
use to price these bonds.
And as you saw before, three
different providers 30 years
in the market, they have severe
disagreement of an easy bond.
There is no way to determine
which one is better or not.
A lot, we have to rely
to subjective expertise
of the traders.
And one reason I
joined BlackRock--
because I was in a company
where there was a big trading
desk because of the amount
of work the company has.
So I was learning a lot.
I thought to be an
expert in pricing bonds
and then, given the right
price to estimated liquidity,
I realized, no.
And I learned a lot
from our traders.
So now how do we
transform this know-how
without automatizing
[INAUDIBLE] know-how?
So you should remember the
benchmark price problem, no?
And then what we are
trying to do here
is basically collect and wait.
Different pricing
source and learning
how to weight this from
feedback that we receive
from our traders
in a UI and trying
to apply NLP to their comments.
So really, when they
disagree on the price,
they tend to ask,
in English, why
or put it in English
better than mine.
And then with NLP,
we try to extract
features to adjust our model.
We are on the beginning
of this journey,
but this is cool stuff.
It was an idea enacted
[INAUDIBLE] two of my guys
last year, and now we are
trying to make this a reality.
This is just to introduce what
I think the same final answer
that I mentioned yesterday
in the AI spotlight,
where I see the biggest
improvements, impacts
of machine learning on finance,
something that I'm not expert.
So maybe I'm shooting
myself and keeping myself
out of the job that is NLP.
I'm a user of NLP.
I'm not building models in NLP.
But if you think
of what is finance,
it's collecting data
from the market,
collecting information
from the provider,
and trying to do what?
To forecast people's behavior.
So there is the
assumption that a volume
of published in the market, a
trade that happened in a stock
exchange, aerating, the
fact that the bond is
this sector or
not this sector is
something that will
enable you to forecast
the behavior of the market.
Why don't you go at the
source when you see people
talking about the market?
So doing NLP and
textual analysis.
SPEAKER 1: Good afternoon.
The expo floor will be
closing in 15 minutes.
STEFANO PASQUALI: OK.
SPEAKER 1: Please make
your way to the escalators
and the main lobby.
Thank you.
STEFANO PASQUALI: Thank you.
OK.
So basically, guys, if
you want me to stop,
you could have a less
violent way to stop me, no?
I see the time here,
so it was fine.
Anyway.
So before they call
security to kick me out,
so this is the application.
In the market, if someone
then in BlackRock,
all the applications are NLP.
So people are using
NLP to apply NLP
to the transcription of the
company conference call.
Identify less obvious linkages
between stocks, the similarity.
Text-based industry
classification.
And the last one,
what I think is
going to be a dramatic,
revolutionary input
in my modeling--
news sentiment
index for liquidity.
So somebody doing this engine
to scrape textual news telling
to me which is the sentiment
on liquidity, I'm pretty sure--
I have no proof on this--
I'm pretty sure
that this feature
will drive the vast majority of
the performance of the model.
So far, nobody was
able to produce for me
very high quality
sentiment on liquidity,
but the technology and
the people are evolving.
And I'm really hopeful on NLP.
So to conclude, then I asked--
I give seven, eight, six minutes
to Q&A. This is recapping our
[INAUDIBLE] this picture
with the cyborg man,
the robot machine shaking
the hands of the human being.
That's exactly the concept
of pushing for innovation.
BlackRock has, as well,
a big technology culture.
It's always been
pushing for innovation.
I am getting bored if I don't
play with some fancy tools.
So we push for innovation,
but in a not reckless way,
because we have the problem
or the fiduciary role
to our investors.
So it's always to find the
balance between performance
of the model and transparency,
interpretability.
The model surveillance
that we are observing
is becoming more severe.
And that is-- what is
the ideal topic for us?
Clearly, the infrastructure,
security similarity, NLP,
reinforcement, and
transparent learning
are the things we
think we are and we
want to investigate
to see if we can seek
some performance in our model.
So be careful.
Machine learning is
not the holy grail.
And we want to use it
only when advantageous.
We are able to prove that there
are already some cases where
we're adding value.
We [INAUDIBLE] in the lab.
More to come.
The big push will
be when there will
be some interpretability
ability tools.
Then you don't have any
problem to go while deep
and try everything you want.
I stop here.
OK, so it's been a pleasure.
It's a long journey.
First time that an
Italian finished
before the time, the deadline.
So note this as a big
event, and so thank you
very much for your attention.
We'll see you soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]